there there folks that run away from the  sound of battle and then there are folks  that run towards the nose of the guns  and we are those guys they move towards  danger that's our job I've served with a  lot of great men lot of great women but  that particular group have become my  family know what else I've been thinking  about its we should do when we get out  of here man yeah yeah I always wanted to  open the pitar shot what is in yellow  please some awesome tunes will you get  my dad involved yeah make it a whole  little family business yeah  I've never had a brother before you so  multiple times I know guys put their  lives on the life for me and I know  there were times when I did the same for  other people and that that doesn't go  away right now on this roof my  responsibility is to the safety of all  of these men okay everyone and I need  you here with me instead I need you  [Music]  you